so many of us are familiar with woloson
krumin those wonderful stop-motion
shorts that just had us not always
laughing but intrigued they were more
likeable than they were funny though
granted there were definitely some very
good jokes in them and we always enjoyed
the creativity and imagination that went
into making well now they have their
first feature-length film woloson
Grumman the curse of the way around it
in some respects it's the most
imaginative and tries the most jokes out
in other respect you kind of get the
feeling maybe was trying a little too
hard to please audiences which is not to
say it's bad it's just part of the charm
of wallace and gromit was that it was
just sort of doing its own thing it
could be quiet it could be awkward it
can be weird and this one probably
because I had more of a budget
definitely seemed more like a
crowd-pleaser but in some respects it
sort of succeeded for those who don't
know walls and drum is a story about an
inventor and his dog the inventor of
Wallace constantly has Harebrained
Schemes that his dog Grum it always has
to rescue him from and in this film
their rabbit exterminators well so know
they don't really exterminate the
rabbits they just sort of take them off
the property and well usually give them
a home at their place but one of
Wallace's inventions goes awry what a
shock when it accidentally creates a
ware rabbit a giant creature that goes
through all the people's farms and
destroys their crops Wallace and Gromit
are on the case but Gromit finds out
there might be a more interesting twist
to this than they think
and no I won't give away any more than
that the movie is sort of a strange mix
because I can say I probably laughed
more at this Wallace & Gromit than I did
the other ones it just seemed like they
were putting in more jokes and more
fourth-wall humour but the one question
you did constantly have to ask yourself
is did this work better as a half-hour
short and personally yeah I think it
sort of did something about squeezing it
into this short amount of time strangely
enough made it seem more large and epic
the villains I remember being especially
threatening from those shorts and this
one is just sort of a pompous ray
Fiennes is just sort of like the typical
show-off jerk who doesn't get the joke
and there's not much to him maybe
because the shorts were kind of on a
smaller scale you were more impressed
when they did something legitimately
large
in a movie you're already sort of
expecting something large so it doesn't
really surprise you it just sort of
gives you what you're expecting but if
what you're expecting isn't bad like me
then this movie isn't really bad either
it's still wallace and gromit it's still
the same characters it's still the same
circumstances they usually get in I just
think it might have worked better if it
wasn't a half hour short but for what it
is it's a fun little movie I can't
really save the solution is make it
smaller or make it bigger but it's
delighted it's kind of hard to dislike
something as innocent as wallace and
gromit it's not motion animation is
always a spectacular the sets are
probably among the biggest that the
studio has ever done and it still has
two characters we really like being the
two characters we really like I can't
say it's the strongest out of what
wallets and from it have done but I
still think is pretty likable if you're
a wallace and gromit fan check it out if
you've never seen them before
I definitely say start with the shorts
first
you